a full moon over a vigil in memory of
the victims of the Columbine High School
massacre but many consider America's
first mass school shooting took place in
the community of Littleton Colorado
April 20th 1999 20 years ago today the
attack by to Columbine seniors killed 12
fellow students and a teacher and may
have set the stage for the school
shootings that haunt us to this very day
Barry Petersen is in Littleton this
morning Barry
good morning Anthony this is the
Columbine memorial to the 12 students
and the teacher killed that day each
person has a plaque with something
personal here's Daniel Mauser was
willing to share his wisdom and
knowledge this is a place where people
come to remember but for one man who
knew all these people as friends or
students and who survived that day there
is no way to forget Kikki labor was in
his first year teaching English and
history of Columbine I can see the
silhouette of a gunman holding a long
rifle but I can also hear gunfire he's
still teaching at Columbine and when you
talk to him you wonder was it 20 years
ago or just yesterday you were there 20
years and yet it's still pain in your
voice
trauma has memory and we can can feel it
students still walk those same halls
learning English and math and these days
how to survive an active shooter the
drills aren't overkill we only do one
lockdown drill a year I feel extremely
safe at Columbine and while that may
change students futures it does not ease
Keke's past what was left behind in all
of those years after Columbine and we
just moved on trying to to heal whatever
that looks like there's always the push
to move forward which drives me crazy
the largest group is that non physically
wounded traumatized population and and
then also the families that get lost
in that as well after the murders at
Sandy Hook elementary school their staff
asked Kiki to come and share his
insights and his memories to see it on
their faces in their eyes was so
difficult but when you spoke with those
people and they saw that you were only I
wouldn't say on the other side but on
the mending part of this did that help
yes yes I think it's a it's a really
important part of that healing to have
that opportunity to meet with somebody
or talk to somebody who can relate to
your experience
Steve Segal agrees he was a victims
advocate for the Denver District
Attorney
what are they suffering they're going
through a time where their wounds have
been ripped open it's flooding back it's
flooding back in Kiki's memories include
this newspaper from the day after I saw
seems like this but I didn't know what
it was gonna be you know how big it was
didn't know how life-changing it could
be but I really kind of wonder if we
should always keep this going on to
remember what happened and what the
lessons were we really need to keep the
dialogue and the dialogue means the
memories well yeah the memories I mean
that's part of it I mean it's a package
deal when it comes down to you know
these mass shootings school shootings
with those you're inevitably you're
going to be dealing with that and it's
part of what we have to deal with until
something changes
there will be a remembrance service here
later this afternoon it'll draw huge
crowds students survivors family members
and I'm sure like keiki many of them
will also be wondering how many more of
these before something changes Michelle
all right Barry I tell you it is no
questions can answer the why yeah in all
the stories that I've seen this week
what's so powerful is how how touched
everybody ever lives and what Kiki said
trauma has memory is is so spot-on
and even that idea that you're not on
the other side of it
no you're mending and think about that
20 years later you're still mending and
you haven't gotten to that other side
yeah I was I was the first from CBS at
Newtown and I will never ever forget the
first moment of looking at my phone and
seeing 20 children dead after thinking
it may have been just a fight yeah I
mean it just is it stays with you it
stays with you